this past week andrew tate has been
banned from just about every social
media platform you can imagine one
notable exception is twitch where it
seems he may have actually deleted his
own channel let's look at why that's
important and try and answer the
question of whether or not this will
affect tate's meteoric rise to fame
all right if you've somehow managed to
avoid seeing or hearing about shock jock
andrew tate over the past few months
then congratulations on finally getting
your internet fixed for the rest of us
he's been pretty hard to avoid clips of
him have been absolutely everywhere and
they all have a couple of things in
common his often young and male fans see
him as a sort of antidote to cancer
culture and a guide for how to be a
modern man but for the vast majority of
people these clips have exposed tate's
misogynistic backwards and just
generally disturbing ideology i'm a
feminist i believe in empowering women
make as much money as you can yeah sure
be be do only fans i wouldn't even mind
my girl doing only fans as long as i
kept all the money you're keeping all of
it though yes she's mine she's my
property so she's selling my property
like if we're gonna rent out my house
then i get the money right you're my
chick or my property you're gonna sell
pictures of my property cool where's my
money tate is a professional kickboxer
who first made a name for himself in a
celebrity world when he was kicked off
of big brother uk in 2016 after a video
emerged online which showed him beating
a woman with a belt the following year
he gained even more notoriety on twitter
by saying that depression wasn't real
much to the anger of mental health
charities and during the metoo movement
he was banned from twitter after stating
that women should quote bear some
responsibility for being raped in april
this year his romanian home was raided
by police as part of a sex trafficking
investigation after reports that an
american woman was being held there
against her will however tate said the
woman was free to leave this summer has
really seen the rise of andrew tate from
small time manosphere pinup to worldwide
internet obsession and twitch has had a
lot to do with that he's appeared on
aidan ross's streams many times where he
sometimes debated with the likes of xuc
and hassan over his controversial
outlooks you came along and said you
came don't interrupt me you came along
and said no that's not true because of
the evidence i came and said i don't
care about the evidence my personal
experience you said i also have personal
experiences and we're all biased i
agreed then you said even if i had
personal experiences that said x i would
ignore them because the internet told me
to believe why i believe what i'm doing
that's not what i said
i said that regardless of my own
personal
biases that i might have
evidence is still more important than my
personal biases he's used this exposure
to help further his hustler's university
program which some have accused of being
a pyramid scheme where members fork over
50 for a discord full of pdf files which
promised to lay out the secrets of being
an online hustler but in actuality don't
seem to provide much more than the first
page of a google search can offer now
for a lot of people it may have felt
that the tape train was picking up speed
but this past week he may have hit a
bump on the track last week tate was
banned from both facebook and instagram
for violating parent company meta's
policies on dangerous organizations and
individuals shortly after tate spoke
about the instagram ban on aiden ross's
stream i have good people on the case i
trust due process with instagram i'm
actually quite understanding of their
position i do understand it very very
well i'm not angry at them in any regard
uh it's not a big loss for me it's not
something i use too often but i do
understand their position because we're
actually living in a world now where
it's kind of strange this is an
unprecedented period of human history
and we have internet sensationalism
global sensationalism on a scale which
has never happened before he was also
banned from tick tock with a
spokesperson for the company telling
insider that quote misogyny is a hateful
ideology that is not tolerated on tick
tock and that their quote investigation
into this content is ongoing by tuesday
youtube had followed suit a spokesperson
told bloomberg the ban came after
multiple violations of community
guidelines and terms of service
including its hate speech policy the
bans led to a series of parodies this
week with tate seemingly being banned
from everything including the likes of
league of legends and the sims 3 store
or even hired by blizzard for his
comments now you might be wondering
where twitch is on the list of platforms
that take has been banned from well it
appears the channel is gone not because
it was banned though but because he
deleted it if you've watched any of our
twitch band videos in the past you'll
know that it's very difficult to get a
twitch ban overturned and also that once
you are banned on twitch you can't
appear on anyone else's stream without
them also getting banned the theory is
that tate deleted his tate speech twitch
channel to avoid this ban altogether and
retain the ability to appear on other
streams so there's been a lot of channel
bans and deletions across the board but
everyone knows that banning someone from
social media doesn't remove them from
the internet altogether this is
particularly true for andrew tate
because perhaps more than any other
online persona in recent years his
message has been spread by others not
him many of the people who have been
pumping out clips of tate on these
platforms have been doing so using his
name and face on their account and quite
often these aren't just your average fan
accounts a lot of them have real
monetary incentives according to the
guardian hustlers university members are
told they can earn up to 10 000 pounds a
month through crypto investing drop
shipping and crucially by earning a 48
commission for each person they refer to
the program so it's really in their
interest to spread his message and get
more people to sign up then there's also
the fact that these videos are raking in
millions and millions of views which
doesn't hurt financially either tate
shut down hustlers university after his
social media band this past week but of
course it's not just affiliate links
that have been generating tate's growth
online he really has made an impact on
his followers and his rhetoric appears
to be firmly lodged in their heads in
fact i don't think it's crazy to assume
that many of his followers will see
these social media bands as the exact
cancel culture that drew them to andrew
tay in the first place a man who has
kicked back many of the progressive
values of the past 60 years advocacy
groups have called on the social media
giants to do more to combat tate's
presence on their platforms even if his
personal accounts are banned some clips
uploaded just this month of andrew tate
have racked up billions of views this
isn't entirely about his personal
accounts and there's no incentive for
these uploaders to stop in fact there's
arguably even more for them to gain now
that the source of these clips has been
somewhat plugged jake paul of all people
tweeted that although he doesn't roll
with andrew tate and may knock him out
in the ring one day he does roll with
freedom of speech he then shared a link
to a video titled andrew tate's final
message now before we dive into his
final message i do just want to say that
this video is over an hour long we're
not going to have time to comb through
this line by line and the reason i'm
really stressing that is because a lot
of what tay says in this video is based
around the media taking what he says out
of context so yeah i will be
paraphrasing a bit here the video starts
with tate discussing childhood
difficulties that he's had to overcome
in life such as his dad telling him to
fight back against school bullies weeks
had passed it was a few weeks they kept
picking on me kept picking on me and i
felt myself sitting there getting more
insecure and the rage was boiling inside
of me and one day one of them slapped me
in the side of the face from behind i
was sitting on the chair he slapped me
in the face from behind
and instantly i don't know what it was
but this was the day i had enough and i
turned with my lunchbox and swung it
over the back of the school bus chair
and caught him and busted his eye clean
over the plastic batman lunchbox take
their moves on to explain how a lot of
what he has said has been twisted or
taken out of context by people online
and he wanted to share the reason he
didn't challenge his critics in the past
and this is the reason why i have not
tried
to dispel these myths as hard as i could
have because i understood that these
people are always going to hate me and
they're always going to lie about me no
matter what i say or do
but considering in light of the final
ban
and considering i have the public
consciousness i think it's extremely
important that for myself and for my
family for people i care about
that i tell the truth and i make the
truth known to the world he also said he
doesn't mind people disagreeing with him
or him being seen as controversial
but that people have lied about him i
would never
shout for any of the people who disagree
with anything i say to be silenced or
cancelled because i don't think that
that helps the world i think that
discourse is always going to be the way
that we lead ourselves to the truth and
if anybody has anything
contrary to say about any of my points
of view i welcome it i like to hear it
and as long as it's in a respectful and
adult manner i often platform it on my
platforms as much as possible all of
this really lies at the heart of tay's
message that the world has kind of got
him twisted he believes that the people
who upload clips of him which he claims
are taken out of context from long-form
videos are only in it for the views and
clout somebody i have no idea who has
made a tick tock where it says men do
certain things and it shows videos of me
driving around in cars spending money
and women do certain things and it shows
women cleaning
women do certain things
and men do certain things
somebody off their own back somebody
else has made that video i didn't tell
them to i don't know who they are i
don't know what their account is it's
just viral on the internet somewhere
and now i look like i'm saying women
should only clean and men should only
run around with cars and women and money
i didn't say that
i didn't say that at all i said that
women should be protected and provided
for but because a small clip was taken
out of context and used against me and
weaponized now i look like i've said
things i did not say now there's
definitely something to be said for
people on the internet editing content
to spin it into something else entirely
but a lot of the clips that have got
people worked up over the past few
months seem to have their context mostly
intact there's no editing going on in
these clips nothing being spliced in
like in the example that take gave they
really are just lifted from the videos
in a way in which their context and
meaning remain the same takes final
message video finishes with him musing
about his return to social media which
yes he does plan to do but he insists
that he will not make a return until
he's figured out a way to stop people
from twisting his words the video
finishes with a clip from tate's
appearance on the nelk podcast with a
teaser for an apparent stage two that's
on the way this is stage one of a
three-step plan
so i'm gonna be viral for a little bit
longer then step two begins
the conquest is continuing
so this is just the beginning because a
lot of people are saying like you're
going to fall off soon this is just
a minute no problem so if the rise of
andrew tate online and his expulsion
from social media is stage one what
exactly does stage two entail we can
speculate about that all day but hassan
one of tate's most vocal critics over
the past few months believes that all of
this is part of a cycle that goes far
beyond tate it's a big l major all for
andrew major all for the platforms in
general but most importantly a major l
for 12 year old boys all around the
united states of america will now be
rudderless they will be looking for the
other next misogynistic hydra head that
will pop up the only thing we do know
for sure is that if and when tate does
make his return be on twitch tick tock
youtube instagram there's gonna be a lot
of people tuning in both fans and
critics alike
[Music]
so
you